alors on a tous déjà eu ce type de
journées bien remplies si remplie qu'on
arrive à réaliser tout ce qu'on avait
prévu de faire et même davantage
j'ai demandé à ceux qui ont connu ce
type de journée et qui en ont retiré une
certaine satisfaction de bien vouloir
lever la main c'est cool comme sentiment
non et inversement qui a déjà eu ce type
de journée absolument affreuse où rien
ne va rien de marche comme prévu on
n'arrive pas à mener à bien la moindre
petite action et la fin de la journée on
rentre chez soi en se disant mais
j'aurais mieux fait pas me lever il ya
beaucoup plus de main levée vous êtes
modeste alors pourquoi sommes nous si
fiers de nous quand on arrive à insérer
davantage de rendez-vous dans des
agendas déjà surchargés et qu'on arrive
à battre le record du monde de repassage
de chemise dans la même journée c'est
pas une question de survie
on n'est plus là pas non plus une
question de reconnaissance parce que la
plupart du temps personne ne nous voit
atteindre nos objectifs nos petits
objectifs
et pourtant c'est dans nos gènes à tous
on est comme ça dans nos gènes eh bien
peut-être pas peut-être que cette
volonté de toujours faire plus et
toujours faire mieux
elle n'est peut-être pas si instinctive
et naturel que ça moi j'essaie de vous
démontrer dans les quinze minutes qui
suivent que la productivité parce que
c'est de ça dont on parle
et bien c'est un réflexe un
conditionnement un comportement que
l'homme c'est inculquer pendant des
années des millénaires mais avant ça je
me fais un peu l'avocat du diable parce
que c'est vrai que c'est vrai que si on
regarde à travers les âges vous pourrez
pas voir autre chose mais moi je le vois
bien la productivité des hommes et la
croissance économique
elles sont concomitantes après tout
leurs logiques sont proches elles
mesurent toutes deux une production ou
un revenu il ya de ça quelques années
ont été un tout petit peu avant
l'antiquité nos ancêtres après des
années d années des millénaires
d'errance finissent par se sédentariser
alors du jour au lendemain ces nomades
qu'ils ne sont plus
ne sont plus simplement tributaire des
territoires qu'ils traversent mais
s'approprie l'environnement qu'il
colonise alors il instaure un quotidien
leurs activités commencent à devenir
répétitif val de vienne juste assez
répétitif pour pouvoir installer une
certaine stabilité qui leur permet de
s'organiser
nous qui s'organise il crée là il
invente la division du travail donc
falloir qu'il se répartissent les tâches
au sein de la communauté comme on se
répartirait les postes dans une équipe
de foot
certains deviennent chasseurs d'autres
pêcheurs d'autres encore bûcheron biens
militaires
après des années et des années des
millénaires où nous n'avons connu que la
débrouille il fallait savoir marcher
courir grimper aux arbres connaître les
animaux pour pas finir dans un estomac
les baies les herbes pour ne pas finir
intoxiqué voilà qu'on accepte de
déléguer une partie de ces bonnes
pratiques de la subsistance de ses
responsabilités de notre existence à la
communauté et voilà qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'en fait en se répartissant les tâches
et bien on fait mieux et on fait plus
alors tout ce petit monde et pêcheurs
les chasseurs etc
tout ce petit monde évalue évoluent en
parfaite cohérence parce que la
productivité ou l'efficacité des 1
bénéficier aux autres au travers des
échanges commerciaux map surproduction
je te là c'est douteux l'échangent
contre ta propre surproduction la
productivité n'est la croissance aussi à
peine au dessus de zéro pour cent par an
mais l'homme a choisi sa route celle de
la productivité et c'est un choix on
sait convenu du nomadisme pendant près
de deux millions d'années
la seule limite à ce ce système de la
productivité pour ça qu'on reste aux
alentours de 0 % de croissance par an eh
ben c'est l'énergie humaine
qu'à cela ne tienne quelques révolutions
industrielles plus tard après avoir
découvert et a servi de nouvelles
sources d'énergie vapeur l'électricité
le carburant
la production est décuplé le résultat
c'est que pendant 200 ans de 1800 aux
années 2000 et bien la croissance
explose
jusqu'aux années à partir de 1975 où s
infléchit alors qu'est ce qui se passe
en 1975 pour que la productivité
s'infléchissent nous sommes au paroxysme
de la productivité on a inventé le
taylorisme le fordisme le lean
manufacturing
on produit avec des robots on ne
communique plus que par e-mail et la
plupart de nos processus en entreprise
sont supportés par des applicatifs
surpuissant pourtant la croix la
conséquence enfin le constat c'est que
la croissance économique est bien
s'infléchit ldc l'air le constat c'est
que la productivité n'est plus le moteur
de la croissance et si la productivité
n'est plus le moteur de la croissance
économique
on est en droit de se poser une nouvelle
question est ce qu'elle ne lui est pas
toxique est ce qu'elle ne serait pas le
poison de notre économie
alors on va peut-être venir un petit peu
en arrière avant d'aller plus loin et se
poser la question se rappeler un peu ce
que c'est que la productivité je vous
promets c'est la dernière équation
gouverner ce soir mais vous la verrez
deux fois la productivité c'est une
c'est un rapport une bête division entre
des quantités qu'on produit et des
ressources qu'on consomme du travail dé
fond qu'on investit dans une entreprise
partir de là le mécanisme il est
simplissime
si vous voulez augmenter votre
productivité il suffit d'augmenter votre
production de réduire les coûts
augmenter votre production
il vous faudra unir deux conditions la
première c'est d'avoir une demande
suffisamment stable et prévisible pour
pouvoir vendre les produits que vous
produisez en plus de ce que vous
produisez d'habitude sinon vous allez
faire du stock
la deuxième c'est d'avoir des fonds
pouvoir investir dans de nouvelles
capacités de production
et ça demande aussi une certaine
stabilité dans la demande parce que
sinon vous pourrez pas les rembourser
vos investissements et réduire les coûts
finalement ce n'est pas tellement plus
compliqué il suffit de faire ce qu'on
fait depuis quatorze mille ans on divise
le travail à nouveau les diviser le
travail aujourd'hui
ça veut dire tout simplement
spécialisée de plus en plus concentré
des opérateurs des services d pourquoi
pas des boîtes complète sur des
périmètres de tâches de plus en plus
restreint et de plus en plus répétitif
mais la division du travail
finalement est très très lié à la
production elle n'a de sens que si
l'activité est suffisamment stable pour
pouvoir justifier de micro spécialisé
vos opérateurs
elle n'a de sens que si la demande
permet de concrétiser le gain
d'efficacité
donc je vais vous donner un exemple
celui d'un boulanger qui oublieraient du
jour au lendemain tout ses recettes pour
se consacrer aux pains aux raisins
blonds g deviendrait super efficace et
imes immensément riche
dans la mesure où ses clients
n'achèterai plus que des pans raison
mais si la clientèle change de boue et
de vendre des pains au chocolat le
système s'écroule
donc finalement que vous souhaitiez
augmenter la production ou réduire les
coûts c'est la même chose vous avez
besoin de deux choses d'un vestiaire de
grossir
finalement et puis de stabilité la
stabilité peut-on parler encore de
stabilité aujourd'hui peut-on parler de
stabilité des ressources alors même que
certaines matières qui font office de
commodité aujourd'hui vont disparaître
d'ici 2030 2050
peut-on parler de stabilité dans un
contexte de dégradation ont confirmé de
l'environnement alors même que les
hantent les compagnies d'assurance
s'enrichissent de plus en plus de
sinistres naturels chaque année peut-on
parler de stabilité dans un monde où les
conflits persistent et prennent des
formes de plus en plus sournoise et
surprenante terrorisme attaque
informatique toutes les régions du monde
sont concernées toutes les sociétés sont
déstabilisés stabilité économique
les crises elles semblent se succéder
crise des subprimes en 2008 crise de la
dette quelques années plus tard d'abord
quel point commun à toutes ces crises
quelle que soit l'origine
eh ben c'est le décrochage de la demande
la volatilité
une grosse entreprise ultra productive
ultra intégré verticaliser et bien il ne
vacille pas parce que quelque part sur
la planète une bulle spéculative
s'effondre non elle va s'y passe que du
jour en main plus personne n'achète les
produits elle va s'y passe que la
productivité a rendu nos entreprises
enfin inciter nos entreprises à investir
toujours plus dans des capacités de
production qui soudainement ne servent
plus à rien et ne peuvent plus être
remboursés donc dans ce contexte un peu
nouveau dans un monde de plus en plus
incertain et depuis d'horreur de plus en
plus difficile à prévoir
est ce que le modèle de la productivité
peut encore fonctionner dans un monde de
plus en plus incertain est ce que le
modèle de l'entreprise à 5,5 milles
treize mille vingt mille trente mille
cent cinquante mille employés est encore
compatibles et bien non il n'est pas
compatible
donc on a un nouveau problème comment
rester compétitif dans un monde il n'est
plus régie par les lois de la
productivité la solution est celle ci il
faut déconstruire la productivité en
entreprise et il faut s'engager sur un
nouveau chemin celui de l'improductivité
alors ça ça se fait ça se fait en trois
temps c'est un chemin en trois temps le
premier d'entre eux est bien ces
innovations alors s'agit pas de
maîtriser des dernières technologies
quoique ça peut aider les dernières
matière
de dernière génération mais il s'agit de
deux devancés dans la rupture de
discuter avant de se retrouver disrupt
est soi-même innovation aujourd'hui
c'est plus un groupe de scientifiques
qui tourne en rond dans un laboratoire
avec un budget infinie l'innovation
aujourd'hui c'est un cap
une stratégie qui tire toute
l'entreprise est le point de départ
il est simple c'est un portefeuille que
mon équilibre avec deux types de projets
des projets d'innovation incrémentale
qui permettent à l'entreprise de
renouveler son offre sur des marchés
déjà existants
une nouvelle couleur pour un vêtement ou
une nouvelle génération pour iphone et
puis des projets d'innovations radicales
qui ont pour ambition de déstabiliser
des marchés existants et d'en vont faire
émerger de nouveaux et bien ces exemples
de blaquart qui a structuré le le marché
delà du covoiturage en france
et puis c'est tous ces exemples de
créateurs de désintermédiation et
d'alternative que son wave que sont par
exemple kickstarter mais l'innovation
c'est pas l'apanage de petites boîtes
peu formaté que sont ces start-up mais
ça présuppose de mettre en place un
certain nombre de 2,2 mécanique dont je
vais vous parler immédiatement alors la
première d'entre elles et c'est aussi
notre deuxième étape dans vers le verlan
productivité si vous suivez c'est
l'agilité l'agilité c'est la capacité ou
une entreprise de mettre sur le bon
marché au bon moment le bon produit
donc c'est la capacité d'arrivée avant
les autres avant sa concurrence avec un
produit ou un service innovant et
d'exploiter la demande
là où elle est quand elles existent
parce que celle ci est éphémère cerci et
volatil car comment elle fait
l'entreprise agile enfin comment elle
fait l'entreprise pour devenir agile et
bien elle positionne où elle
repositionne le consommateur au centre
de son système
elle va développer des versions tout
juste abouti mais suffisante de ses
produits de ses services et va les
tester avec le client directement pour
prendre une décision cruciale
rapidement que les autres celle de
persévérer avec un produit
éventuellement d'ajuster le tir
complètement d'arrêter d'un projet qui
n'est pas porteur c'est une entreprise
qui reconnaît le caractère éphémère de
la demande et qui est perméable aux
clients et ça ça s'organise en
entreprise alors les entreprises
productiviste qu'on connaît tous on
connaît très très bien sûr celle qu'on a
aujourd'hui créées sont en train là
maintenant à l'heure où on parle de
créer des systèmes extrêmement complexe
pour venir croiser des données dans tous
les sens
analyser des ventes passées et tenter de
dessiner des projections sur le futur et
bien l'entreprise agile elle fait pas ça
l'entreprise agit est ce qu'on s'en est
ce qu'on tente d'exploiter la proximité
qu'elle a avec le client et elle dans
les fêtes 1 elle va donner le contrôle
de son système de sa chaîne
d'approvisionnement à ceux qui sont en
contact direct avec le client des
commerciaux itinérants par exemple ou
alors le client lui-même et elle se
rapproche encore plus du client en
allant produire directement à sa porte
en local et en faisant ça eh bien elle
supprime toutes les étapes
intermédiaires de prises de commandes de
planification d'ordonnancement de
dispatch de business analysis plus
besoin de tout ça peut-être qu'un jour
elle arrivera même a confié aux clients
jusqu'à sa production
on a vu deux talk insu ravin à vue
notamment de talk 1 sur la production a
dit yves l'impression 3d et un autre sur
les objets connectés
voici une application l'entreprise agile
alors l'agilité finalement c'est poids
c'est une entreprise qui se recentre sur
le client et qui limite les activités au
minimum nécessaire mais le minimum
nécessaire c'est faire moins et faire
moins faire mieux pour le client mais
c'est accepter de ne plus tout maîtriser
dans l'entreprise
et ça ça plaît pas à nos boîtes
et bien pourtant dans un monde incertain
il va bien falloir en prendre des
risques bonne nouvelle c'est que on peut
réduire son exposition au risque
une façon très simple c'est en limitant
sa dépendance à des ressources qui
pourraient disparaître en cas de crise
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que pour
limiter sa dépendance
contrairement à la vie de tous les jours
en entreprise il faut accepter de perdre
le contrôle prenons un exemple tout
simple ne plus dépendre de ses
ressources financières
et bien c'est accepter de ne plus
investir révolution pour l'entreprise le
plus investir c'est accepter
d'externaliser une partie de ses
opérations
accepter de ne plus contrôler ses
produits ou plutôt de ne plus dépendre
de sa propre production
et bien c'est accepter de vendre moins
de produits et c'est concevoir le fait
d'en produire moins et pourtant moins de
production mon investissement moins de
dette moins de risques mais le plus dur
le plus inconcevable pour une entreprise
aujourd'hui c'est d'accepter de ne plus
contrôler son organisation ses salariés
donc c'est supprimer les procédures
l'organigramme
les indicateurs de performance pour
tendre vers un modèle de travail
réunifiée et indivisible
ce modèle de travail son métier ni
organigramme hiérarchie et bien c'est le
plus malléable d'entre tous l'entreprise
devient résiliente et c'était la
troisième et ultime étape vers la
productivité
mais l'étape la plus dure à franchir
alors on l'a vu c'est un chemin qui est
très long et moi de ce talk on arrive à
la fin
j'aimerais vous retiriez deux choses
deux idées fortes la première c'était un
productivité ça n'est pas simplement et
bêtement le contraire de la productivité
mais c'est un relais de croissance
économique
la seconde j insiste là-dessus c'est que
la marche à gravir et très grande parce
qu'il faut détricoter tous les
mécanismes productiviste en entreprise
et moi j'ai besoin de vous ce soir
investisseurs chercheurs enseignants
étudiants donc futurs décideurs en
entreprise chefs d'entreprise pour faire
essaimer l'idée dans vos entreprises
et bien qu'il existe d'autres parcours
d'autres chemins que la productivité car
celle ci car celui ci est toxique
et puis pour démarrer une réflexion de
fond sur la structure de nos entreprises
avant que la prochaine crise ne
fragilise irrévocablement notre notre
économie merci
merci beaucoup à la vie